beaucoup de conditions posées tout comme
un certain nombre d'exigences ans laura
on aura compris armelle charrier bonjour
on va discuter de quoi concrètement
aujourd'hui alors concrètement ce
qu'espère douanes c'est d'ouvrir une
voie vers des vraies négociations
c'est-à-dire d'avoir comme on l'a
entendu ces derniers temps dans le par
exemple discours 2nd ce qui commence à
ouvrir un petit peu la porte au dialogue
et poutine qui semble dire qu'il peut se
contenter de l'est de l'ukraine on ne
sait pas si c'est vrai on ne sait pas si
c'est juste des princes qui ont été
posées un moment particulier et ce
qu'ils espèrent bien sûr c'est de
pouvoir dire regardez à partir de ce
moment là on a vu un cheminement dans le
discours diplomatique
concrètement c'est trop tôt pour avoir
une avancée qui sort aujourd'hui à
istanbul parce qu'on voit bien la
situation sur le terrain alors il ya
évidemment les couvreurs ministère il ya
évidemment le cessez le feu mais pour
les turcs davantage c'est qu'ils ont un
lien avec les ukrainiennes et avec les
russes n'oubliez pas que les turcs
tiennent quand même les détroits donc si
les navires russes doivent quitter et
aller vers la méditerranée passe par le
bosphore et donc ils sont obligés de
passer devant les russes en même temps
les russes sont souvent à leurs côtés
sur des terrains on l'a vu par exemple
en syrie mais c'est ce même maire
douanes qui va aussi donner des drones
aujourd'hui aux ukrainiens qui leur
permettent d'abattre les avions russes
donc on est dans quelque chose de
compliqué mais qui montre que la turquie
parle en fait à tous les interlocuteurs
la turquie mainate crise